hello in this video i explain
what a kreuz more stable is and how
you can easily create it online
and we'll start with that
kreuzer band are tables that show the
absolute and relative frequencies
of two categorical
variables what are categorical
variables again categorical variables  are, for example,
the gender with the characteristics
male female the preferred
newspaper the frequency of television
or the highest educational qualification so
whenever we want to enter two categorical
variables in
one tablet we can use a cross table
, for example if we enter the
gender and the preferred
newspaper  would like or the preferred
newspaper and the frequency of
television
how do we get to our
cross table say we have created a
questionnaire in which the
participants cross which
sex they have and what their
highest educational qualification is these
little ones  we now leave the questionnaire from
as many
non-responses as possible we can then have the result of the survey displayed
in a table
in this table we see
one person interviewed in each row the first
person interviewed stated, for example,
that she is male and has the
highest educational qualification from a compulsory school
The second person interviewed stated that
she is female and has the highest level of
education
, but we can read very little from this table,
so we use a statistical
software update from and have a
cross table displayed. In this table,
you can see the variable gender and, at
most, the level of education and  it is shown in
each case how often the
respective combination occurs, so
the combination of
female and no degree occurred a total of
six times for all those interviewed,
or the combination of
male without a degree occurred a total of seven times,
so heat up a super with a
cross table  overview of
two categorical variables pair cross
tables give a great
overview they are very often used in
market research
in market research cross tables can be used to
compare customers or products very well
one of the following questions can be
answered, for example which insurance
is preferred by which age group
do the car brands differ in the
city and in the country or which apple variety
sells best at which time of the year
, however, it should be noted that
this statement only applies to the sample
you made if you want to make
a statement about the total population
, you need a square
You are welcome to watch my video
about the keyword rates for this,
but now I would like to show you how you
can create a crosstab online. To do
this, please go to date up de and
click on the statistics calculator
in this table, you can now
copy your own data into it  small
I have prepared
a short example here
. In this example,
when the weather was bad, you simply looked at
how many people come into the lecture hall
who have an umbrella
and who do not have an umbrella and whether
this person is male or female,
you copied your data here
do you see the variables down here
we want to have a cross table for the
variable gender and
umbrella so we just click on
gender and umbrella and
we see our cross table
we see female and male
plotted and has an umbrella with
it yes  And
no, we can of course also have
the percent and the valid percent
output
if you
don't have your variable coded with female and
male but with zero and one, for example, then it
would still
have to change the level in the variable view, namely
from metric  on nominal
otherwise would delta tab thereof a  assuming
that it is a metric
variable and you could then not
place a cross chapel cross tables
can only ever be created if you have two
categorical variables,
i.e. a nominal like the original
brother you would now also like to check whether the
result also applies to the entire population
watch a few times
next video on square testing thanks
for watching and see you next time